Thank you.
We have the O2 here to talk about why it's in the...
Can you do me a favor?
With your eyes, I don't know any difference there is between the two version and the new version because i think we can all agree the version that's 1224 needs to be changed so we don't need to even look at the one which is 1224 correct correct i guess i'll make it official is that've got the Committee of Conference on House Bill 224.
I don't do a whole lot of these things.
That's not certainly my favorite thing to do.
While we're going over the amendment that was just supplied by Senator Waters on a possible change to the civil liability for damage or obstruction to highways, why don't we start with something a little easier and look at the sharing of motor vehicle records by employer access to motor vehicle records.
That did go.
That's on 134.
It was a committee conference this morning.
I just checked in the couple of the members that sat in on it.
It wasn't even discussed.
It passed the House floor and that's on 134.
There was a committee of conference this morning.
I just checked with a couple of the members that sat in on it.
It wasn't even discussed.
It passed the House floor, and it's been signed off on, even though the report's not available, and it's moving to the consent calendar for next week.
Yeah, I think they've seen it to the House.
Yeah.
So is there any need for that to stay on 224?
Anybody's opinion?
No.
Okay.
Do you guys see any reason for it to be on 224.
Anybody's opinion?
No.
Can you guys see any reason for it to be on 224?
Looks like this and what's on the civil opinion.
Well, let's look at that then.
I didn't see any differences either.
You said the version in HB 2 of the civil liabilities portion or amendment is different than what you just handed me?
That's what DOT says.
Kathy can explain it.
Kathy, do you want to try and explain it?
Sure.
Thank you for hearing this.
That's all the difference between what you're talking about.
Thank you for hearing this text.
Welcome to the house and let's see.
The difference between what you have in the hand and what's in HD2 is provision 3.
The heart rate uses estimated cost on the right to the right.
Damages for the high level of highway.
.
HB's office raising us to use estimated costs, but only going forward with future So we have $5 million in pending claims that we want authority to use estimated losses.
So this version doesn't say anything about part three.
Now, what's in the back page, right?
This is only part two.
So is there another section to this that we did that?
well this is that's the that's the new section three well this is still one and two no it's three and three down below so the proposal is to put three into ours so it so it's different than what hb2 says correct it allows them It says this section applies to all pending claims.
So any 500 close to $500,000 worth of claims that are pending right now, they will be able to use the actual act.
The replacement.
The estimated cost.
Which Can I ask a question?
When this was heard in the House Judiciary, was there any issue with the retroactive ability of the consent?
Yes.
Representative, more than the retroactive this is what we've done all the long time.
So when you're talking about where we're here saying pending claims, so it's not retroactive, they're still active claims.
Correct.
They're just waiting to be paid out.
They haven't been indicated.
So it's not like they're going back to an accident that had already been settled and added additional.
No.
It's just, it's pending.
Right.
It was part three in the original version that was introduced in the judiciary.
Yes.
I don't believe in that policy this year, but I know it was in an agent to originally as a governor's office.
That's interesting.
House Judiciary taken out?
House Judiciary had killed the bill because it wasn't that part of the bill because it was an agent to.
They had also objected to the work strictly as a strictly viable and the agreement to take that work strictly.
but senate house judiciary never amended it because they they had the amendment i think available but they determined that because it was in hb2 they didn't need to even deal with it right they didn't need to do any amending and the version of hb2 moved section three which which they had issues in post-judiciary to begin right yes this is great and this is all over a bill that was not even heard in transportation and i don't understand why i think that yeah things happen sometimes yeah okay um any other questions from anybody else i think we've all followed the path from where we are without even even, I don't have to ask, of course, this is what you want this amendment to look like.
This takes care of the procedural problems.
I do agree with the philosophy that the taxpayers shouldn't be paying for things twice.
So if somebody else damages them, they should get paid for.
I don't disagree with that philosophy.
I'm seeing that we're strictly gone, but I agree.
Let's chat for a moment.
Yeah, we'll be right back.
I'm seeing the word strictly gone, but I agree.
Let's chat for a moment.
Yeah, we'll do a break back.
Yep.
Just want to put something on paper.
So I don't do this, I don't do this.
Thank you.
Yeah, I know.
You shouldn't have let me out of the room.
Any need for any more discussion from anywhere?
Are we good?
Let's see.
Recognize Vice Chair for a motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
The House accedes to the Senate position upon further amendment.
That amendment is amendment referring employer access of driving records is approved.
Language referring to civil liability to highways will be amended using language provided this committee, which matches language HP 2 for sections 1 and 2, as well as adding section 3, which applies to pending claims.
As far as an effective date.
On this draft.
On HB2.
The HB2 version is an effective date.
May it the same?
The way this motion, right, well, the way the motion is read, the way I understand it, I wrote it.
we're going to be using this amendment that was provided to the committee by Senator Lauders.
Mirrors the language of HB 2 in terms of sections 1 and 2.
It also adds section 3.
So do we need to change the effective date on 2-24?
What is the effective date?
Effective date shall take effect 60 days after its passage.
And later upon passage.
Yeah, and the revanche has to take effect upon its passage.
It's fine?
So it's fine with 60 days.
We're pulling out section five, right?
And that's amended by the Senate?
Yeah, that's the...
Right, yeah.
So if we remove section five, then we just have sections, the actual effects 60 days after the past.
So I just want to make sure I'll go over to over to us.
Okay, and you're going to keep the 60 day effective day.
Right.
Is there any issue with the judicial branch on on these changes for civil liability?
Again, this is judicial, so I don't usually talk about these things.
I know it's sorry, as far as fine schedules, I know they want it to until the following january i just hope it's not a problem in 60 days let it know no we don't need to we're going to leave the effective date today okay so and yeah uh if you you want me to go down and do this, or you want me to go down and do this?
Either way.
We can go together.
Doesn't matter.
Either way.
And you're the chair of the...
Right.
You're, when you kept referring to Section 5, I didn't bring 134 with me.
Is that what you're looking at?
Thank you.
134 with me.
Is that what you're looking at?
So I'm working off of just to be...
Okay.
All right.
HP 224 is amended by the Senate.
That's what we're working on.
Right?
Yep.
So...
So here, Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay.
Take the levitation.
This is back.
Yep.
That's fine.
So that's.
So that's done.
And then we are replacing replace for this.
Fair enough.
And then, right here, we're striking some of the office.
Why don't I just give this to you?
Okay?
This is what we want to do.
Yeah it's just section five.
Yep.
Okay, so I'm going to give this to you.
No, I know.
That's the thing.
That will work.
Thank you.
We're going to make this a little bit more.
No, I do not.
Maria will let you know when that's right.
Okay, so we need to vote on this to make it official, I guess.
I'll ask the House members, do I agree?
Yes.
Okay, do we have an agreement?
Do the senators agree?
Just make it official.
gonna make it The Senate agrees.
Thank you.
I know you're always busy.
Well, next week.
Okay.
And I think we're going to be meeting with Craig.
And, you know, good meeting with Craig and I got to, I'll share with Craig we've got some edits from getting up here on the RFP.
So I will just, you know, maybe start to fall in place.
I'll probably get to be there for next.
Okay.
Shares all yours.
All right.
This is a conference on House Bill 235.
It's amended.
First, I think we might want to introduce ourselves.
I'll start with myself, Andy Rizzullo.
I represent the town of Hudson and the town of Litchfield.
Mike Gunski representing the town of Boston Suzanne Smith representing Clemence Hebron and Holderman.
Senator Waters, district four, one of the two shirt sleeve senators.
Yes, I am.
We called each other.
Senator Kevin Neibar, district 12.
And Senator Gray is actually in another conference at this particular time.
That's right.
He sends his regards.
Okay.
All right.
House Bill 235, which is the...
we non-concurred and requested a committee of conference.
235 started out as just a small volume, small groundwater withdrawal bill, and it had the PFAS fund attached to it.
We're in motion.
Well, we've worked it out.
The Senate concedes to the House position.
That's okay with you.
Yeah, I think so.
Is there a proper motion for that?
basically we move to accept the house positions accept the house position so we see so that whole amendment that was added on is gone and so the house bill 235 goes on it's a good show I guess you should take a vote on it.
Yes, I vote yes.
Yes.
That's it.
So I'm on House Bill 235.
Yes.
That's it.
So I'm on House Bill 1035.
Send seats to the House position.
Motion to adjourn.
To adjourn.
And we have 28 minutes to go.
28 minutes to go.
We have to do it again.
And I apologize because...
Thank you.
All right.
that Gorder, the Committee of Conference on the House Bill 271.
We've already made the head introductions in the previous bill.
Senator, do you have an amendment?
We do have an amendment, and I was wondering if we could have Mike, one sec.
I'll talk about it.
There are a couple of minor changes with the amendment that you've got to mind that .
You said the law and that's good for some changes.
But Mike, do you need a mic?
Mike, over there?
Yeah, why don't you come over here?
Just a simple fix.
It's a small amendment, not much to talk about.
The way this room is laid out, it's like, it's bad to everybody.
Not feng shui.
Well well this is what we're doing at committee thank you uh for the record my name is mike winced i service director of the waste management division for new hampshire dds uh we said two looking at the amendment that's being offered for HB 271 for this committee conference.
Just the agency had two comments and minor changes that needed to be addressed that we could help improve it.
The first one is on page three line 31 of the amendment.
It's under the heading of RSA 485 H8 duties of the department, and that is being amended by the bill in part.
And we thought that on line 31, it reads as follows, establishing and administering the PFAS remediation loan program to assist municipalities.
Because this amendment also creates and it provides authority for the department to administer grants as well as loans we thought that given the just for clarity and completeness this should now read it should have the word after the words PFAS remediation loan the words and grant should be added and then the word program which is already there should have an s added to it to make it plural so that as we're suggesting it be changed it would read as follows establishing and administering administrating the PFAS remediation loan and grant programs to assist municipalities and then second change is on the final page of the bill for the amendment which is page 5 on line 17 under the effective date section.
And this is a, I'm seeing why this happened.
This was a drafting error from something that we provided earlier, but because of the way the bill's 235 stands on its own now, what this entire bill 271 has proposed to be amended should take effect upon its passage.
There should be no delay for any portion of the bill.
So what we would propose is that Roman one, that line that says section four, this act shall take effect 60 days after his passage should be deleted.
And the new Roman one should read this act shall take effect upon his passage.
And that would be it.
Is there a great overview of the amendment that you want to discuss?
I'd be happy to do that.
I think, you know, as I think the members of the Community Conference know this bill amends RSA 45H which already is passed and is a matter of law that it provides authority for the department to administer a PFAS remediation loan fund to address public drinking water systems and community water systems that have PFAS contamination above standards.
And what this, the primary thing that this amendment would do is to provide also this grant authority to not just loans, but grants, and also to significantly to include municipalities in the categories.
So one of the problems we have is the way that the statute is currently constructed.
really only make loans to existing water systems, which could be run by a municipality or could be, you know, otherwise they a privately run or community water system.
But we know that there are a number of communities where PFAS contamination exists, where there is no public water system, where the municipality does not run public water system.
And so we wanted to make sure that municipalities could seek loan or grant funds to stand up a new water system or maybe build a new infrastructure that would add on to an existing water system.
And so this makes it clear that municipalities, even if they don't currently own or operate a water system, are still eligible to apply for and receive these loan and grant funds.
And then also another significant thing in working with members of the House RR&D committee, it was very important to committee members and I think a lot of members of the legislature to be able to assist private well owners whose wells are impacted by PFAS.
And so there's language in this amendment, and I guess I would direct your attention to page one of the amendment, starting on line 18, which is entitled Implementation of Drinking Water Protection Program, where we have language there that makes it clear that loans and grants can be made.
but it includes a description of municipalities for municipal use that I just described.
But then it also has the second line on D, which is on line 22, that municipalities can seek these funds in order to develop their own municipal programs to assist private well owners whose wells are impacted by PFAS contamination.
And a good example of that is we have one community with a number of wells, private wells above standards, that wants to stand up a rebate program so that their homeowners who whose wells are impacted by PFAS could install, say, a point of use treatment filter under the sink that might cost them to have a contract to do.
It might be a thousand dollars.
This community wants to be able to run a rebate program to help those homeowners defray the cost of installation of that kind of a treatment system.
So this this bill would make it possible for us to administer a grant program, making grants to municipalities so that they could, in turn, stand up local programs to help their citizens whose wells are impacted.
Thank you very much.
So we're presenting this to you folks, and we hope that you like it.
Yes.
Do you have an amendment number, the revised amendment?
No, what?
What do you do?
You'll be able to?
Oh, the new one revised will be there when you go to sign off.
Okay.
Yeah, just for no keeping, that's all so far.
So we got a little less, but I think we probably want to build up revisions.
Yeah.
Probably 1977 as revised as as revised and i'll second that uh comments yes i vote yes oh i oh i said any comments oh comments i want to thank everybody who worked on this I've worked on this..
I had a series of email back and forth with my website over the weekend.
The Municipal Association, and so I think everybody helped us get to yes here.
Thank you, Mike.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
Are we ready to vote?
Aye.
I think we are done.
Thank you all.
Great.
Thank you.
Motion to adjourn?
Second.
All the papers signify by saying aye.
Aye.
Well done.